non
bonsoir françois asselineau merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france
pacification c'est dur à dire sans
surprise ce soir vous vous enviez nos
amis britanniques à l'heure qu'il est
oui beaucoup beaucoup parce que c'est un
jour historique
le dernier obstacle sur le break 6 2
vient d'être levé à une écrasante
majorité au parlement européen et donc
le break ci devait avoir lieu vendredi
le 31 janvier à minuit heure de paris je
les envie beaucoup parce que maintenant
ils peuvent reprendre leur politique une
politique conforme aux intérêts
nationaux conforme à ce que souhaite le
peuple britannique
je rappelle que boris johnson a fait
passer a décidé d'augmenter le smic de 6
2%
le swing britannique va désormais être
supérieurs au smic français ce qui est
interdit par les orientations le rapport
des grandes orientations des politiques
économiques fixés par la commission
européenne à la france qui exige depuis
des années que le smic n'augmente pas
plus vite que l'inflation même plutôt
moins
deuxièmement boris johnson a décidé de
mettre le paquet sur le service de santé
25 milliards de livres sterling par an
et quand 28 milliard d'euros
troisièmement boris johnson a décidé que
désormais la politique en matière
agricole sera orienté vers une
production bio une production de
produits et d'agriculture raisonnée
conformément à ce que souhaite le public
quatrièmement boris johnson a décidé de
re nationaliser une ligne de chemin de
fer allant de londres à l'écossé on
apprend aujourd'hui même qu'il doit y
avoir de nouvelles compagnies d'autres
compagnies à un privé vous savez que
margaret thatcher avait privatisé des
chemins de fer qui vont être
renationalisée pour le défendre les
services publics ce que justement des
années des années d'ultralibéralisme
imposée par la commission européenne
avait anéanti pas moi je constate que
c'est exactement ce que souhaiterait le
peuple français et donc je considère que
si nous nous sortons de l'union
européenne
eh bien on pourrait répondre à la crise
des gilet jaune à la crise des retraites
vous savez que les retraites sont exigés
aussi la réforme des retraites est exigé
aussi par l'union européenne mais
françois sinon
on a l'impression que c'est d'un coup de
baguette magique on sortirait de
l'europe voilà tout s'arrangerait enfin
les caisses de l'état français en
l'occurrence on tout de même vide vous
trouveriez où cet argent alors d'abord
je n'ai jamais dit que tous les
problèmes vont dépendre de l'europe et
que tout serait regrettée de par bell un
coup de baguette magique mais néanmoins
l'essentiel serait récupéré puisque nous
serions de nouveaux maîtres de notre
destin vous savez il ya eu beaucoup de
gens qui ont dit ça va être terrible
avec l'apocalypse et n ya pas du tout la
pokal sur la tranche le fonds monétaire
international vient de révéler qu'en
fait toutes ces prévisions
apocalyptiques qui avait été fait
d'ailleurs du temps de madame christine
lagarde qui maintenant sévit à la bce
que toutes ces prévisions faites et fo
situera pas d'apocalypse premier point
dieu aimant moi j'avais lu des articles
de journaux des gens qui disaient il
faut absolument faire payer aux
britanniques il faut leur faire un break
site très très dur mais je voudrais
rappeler parce qu'il ya des gens qui
vont se poser la question à partir du
1er février vers une négociation pour
avoir un accord de commerce en veulent
au royaume uni et l'union européenne
dont certains disent va falloir payer
serait très bien il faut revenir aux
fondamentaux la france à chaque année
elle vend pour 32 milliards d'euros au
royaume uni et à la chaîne pour 20
milliards d'euros c'est-à-dire qu'on
dégage un excédent commercial de 12
milliards d'euros et en matière de
services ont dégagé un excédent en
matière de services de 6,7 milliards
d'euros ça veut dire que si la france
veut avoir une politique de sanctions de
l'union européenne à l'égard du royaume
uni celui ci peut très bien se venger
parce que vous savez normalement le
client est roi
et si vous savez que vous avez vu ce que
boris johnson a dit il est prêt à
augmenter terriblement les taxes sur le
champagne les produits français
si d'aventuré la france s'amuse assure
finalement large ajoute j'ajoute en plus
que dans ce commerce extérieur c'est
vrai avec la france est vrai avec talent
mal il ya énormément d échanges
interentreprises sur les voitures
l'espace l'aéronautique et c'est donc en
fait personne
personne n'a intérêt à ce que le
président se passe mal et les français
non d'un seul coup découvrir que tout ce
qu'on leur avait raconté et fo de nous
sortir de l'union européenne
ça n'est pas se refermer sur le monde
sait reprendre des échanges normaux
entre puissances ayant par ailleurs
leur liberté leurs politiques nationales
telles que ça va abonder dans votre sens
mais enfin effectivement la présidente
de la commission européenne ursula von
der leyen en europe étaient britanniques
qui m'ont dit qu'ils leur dis plutôt
nous ne serons jamais loin voilà en gros
on vous aimera toujours on sera là et
vice versa ça veut dire quoi
effectivement ça sent pas une rancune
après un divorce non consenties à ses
partisans
vous savez ce que disait ce que dit jean
yanne entre dans les relations
internationales
il n'ya pas d'amitié il ya que des
intérêts si on là j'ai parlé du commerce
extérieur du commerce des services pas
moins des investissements directs
il ya trois mille huit cents entreprises
françaises qui sont implantées aux états
au royaume uni et qui font un chiffre
d'affaires de l'ordre de 120 milliards
d'euros par an alors que dans l'autre
sens il y a ni le jour à 1200
entreprises britanniques qui font un
chiffre d'affaires de 34 milliard
d'euros ça veut dire que en matière
d'investissements directs en matière
d'implantation comme en matière
commerciale comme en matière de services
la france a tout intérêt à faciliter la
signature d'un accord commercial avec le
royaume uni dont il ya eu des remous de
montagne mais vous voyez les
rodomontades on en parle le plus beau
mec le beurre et l'argent du beurre pour
les britanniques
la france dans les autres pays européens
peuvent y perd notamment les pêcheurs
français qui auront moins le droit
d'aller pêcher reçu chez les
britanniques vous êtes sont inquiets
pour vos compatriotes si bien sûr bien
sûr je pense que là aussi la france
n'est pas dénués d'arguments
donc je pense qu'il faudra trouver un
modus vivendi pour les pêcheurs français
et ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
les britanniques reprennent le pouvoir
pour défendre les intérêts nationaux
britanniques mais nous on va toujours on
va on ne pourra toujours pas défendre
les intérêts nationaux français puisque
sur cette affaire de pêcheurs on ne sait
pas nous qui définiront les quotas de
pêche et peut-être que les britanniques
seraient davantage favorables à donner
des quotas de pêche à la france plutôt
que des quotas de pêche à la grèce ou à
la pologne
on n'en sait rien deuxièmement moi ce
que je voudrais ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que les français de façon générale
devrait défendre leurs intérêts
nationaux et en particulier en matière
budgétaire
le départ du royaume uni va faire un
trou dans la caisse de l'ordre de 10 à
14 milliards d'euros
il va falloir le pont blaikie sv qui va
me payer les pays contributeurs nets
l'allemagne et la france ça veut dire
que la france va être taxé de plusieurs
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
à la place des britanniques et tout ça
pour quoi pour aller financer des
infrastructures dans les pays de l'est
pour aller donner de l'argent à
l'ukraine ou à la turquie alors que nous
nous avons nous sommes dans une
situation dramatique budgétairement vous
le disiez tout à l'heure
sortir de l'union européenne s'est
récupéré une marge de manoeuvre
budgétaires considérables 10 milliards
d'euros tout de suite puisque nous
dépensons 10 milliards d'euros de plus
que ce que nous recevons de l'union
européenne et à terme sortir de l'union
européenne c'est ne pas se substituer au
manque à gagner britannique alors les
dépenser dans l'autre sens aussi puisque
selon une étude de bloomberg economics
la facture de break site atteindra les
200 milliards de livres
145 milliards d'euros un peu plus d'ici
la fin de l'année la procédure de sortie
de l'union européenne aura coûté presque
autant que le montant total que le
royaume uni a versé au budget européen
en cours des 47 dernières années ça vous
inspire quoi vous le problème si je
savais ce que c'était une fake news que
c'est du pipeau que tout sa bouille que
tout ça est fondé sur des hypothèses de
croissance complètement démentiel et je
cette info c'est un faux comme il y
avait eu des faux sondages
ça fait partie toujours la ministre le
project faire peur aux gens
non la réalité c'est que la zone euro et
la zone de plus faible croissance
mondiale et que notre royaume uni
n'étant d'ailleurs pas dans la zone euro
avait quand même été affectés par cette
faible que ce faible dynamisme l'union
européenne de façon générale est une
espèce de poids mort qui pèsent sur les
économies des pays de l'union européenne
le royaume uni on va voir vous savez ce
qu'il va se passer on va voir ce qui va
se passer
et pour nous c'est un formidable comment
dirais-je test grandeur nature pour la
première fois un grand pays de l'union
européenne sort de l'union européenne et
on va maintenant pouvoir voir les
français vont pouvoir constater ce qui
se passe pour de bon j'invite d'ailleurs
on organise une grande fête vous me le
permettez vendredi soir à paris 23 rue
basfroi paris 11e
de 20h à 1h du matin on va avoir
d'ailleurs de nombreux responsables
politiques beaucoup de journalistes qui
vont venir également des anglais des
messages de ministre britannique
pour fêter ce break 6 et une eux ce
n'est pas une soirée huppert c'est une
soirée fives le break site
eh bien je n'invite ce qui me regarde
s'ils veulent venir acs a déjà qu'il ya
beaucoup de demandes de primes et
beaucoup beaucoup de médias en actualité
nationale c'est évidemment toujours
dominé par la réforme des retraites ce
huitième journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui
dans la rue mais on sait voilà par les
sondages effectivement qu'une écrasante
majorité de français est toujours contre
cette réforme avec désormais une fronde
parlementaire après notamment les
remarques du conseil d'état le
gouvernement qui semble persister et
signer une réaction une explication
écoutez moi je les dires dit monsieur
macron devrait arrêter les frais le
gouvernement plus un seul ministre ne
peut sortir sans être course et
d'ailleurs les députés en marche même se
terre tellement ils ont peur d'être
course et moi je poussais nous
participons huppert participent à des
élections municipales je vois comme sûrs
dans un certain nombre de deux
circonscriptions tas de mairie les
candidats de en marche n'ose même pas
dire qu'ils sont en marche ils ont honte
de leur étiquette voilà où l'on en est
on a paraît-il une vidéo qui a été
saisie vous savez au théâtre des bouffes
du nord où on voyait monsieur macron
avec madame trognee son épouse paraît-il
courir comme des dératés devant la peur
que d'être arrêté par la foule
on est dans une situation ubuesque ça ça
vous inspire quoi ça a servi le coup de
gueule de robert badinter cher que ça ne
porte pas que même en tant que démocrate
ce genre de scène est obligé mais
d'abord j'ai été surpris que monsieur
badinter ne s'émeuvent pas non plus des
personnes qui sont éborgné mutilé etc
je suis surpris que monsieur badinter
nous appellent à la démocratie mais la
démocratie c'est quoi au bout du compte
c'est au peuple français d'obéir à
monsieur maquereau ou à monsieur macron
d'obéir au peuple français
tous les sondages montrent que 70% des
français sont contre
il veut imposer cette réforme parce
qu'il a le pistolet sur la tempe de la
commission européenne je rappelle que la
réforme des retraites est demandée par
le rapport annuel des grandes
orientations des politiques économiques
et ceci depuis longtemps je rappelle que
beaucoup de français commencent à
comprendre que cette retraite dite
universelle qui d'ailleurs n'est plus
universel parce qu'ils sont c'est dès
maintenant c'est les sapeurs pompiers
avant c'était les policiers et c'est
donc en fait si d'ailleurs c'était si
génial que ça pourquoi est ce que le
gouvernement cède sur des différentes
catégories socioprofessionnelles
en réalité il s'agit d'avoir une
retraite prétendument
universal mais en fait par points dont
l'objectif est d'abord y re les
retraités pour pousser les plus aisés
qui d'ailleurs ne cotiseront plus au
dessus d'un certain montant pour pousser
les plus aisés à faire de la retraite
par des confusions parce qu'au-delà d'un
certain revenu apparemment il y a plus
de cotisations donc là aussi à d'autres
confessions écouter les français ne
veulent pas de cette réforme
ça ce conseil d'état car selon les
sondages tous le conseil d'état a fait
c'est une institution extrêmement police
et ainsi nous sommes au milieu de la
haute fonction publique avec des gens
qui sont une très grande urbanité et
d'une urbanité exquise
il le conseil d'état fait à des halles
portable comme apporter au gouvernement
une réponse comme on a très rarement vu
dans la république
en gros c'est ni fait ni à faire le
budget le projet n'est absolument pas
financer n'est pas bouclé on est dans
une espèce d'impréparation général et
tout ça dans un espèce de chaos social
qui ne fait que s'aggraver
je suis allé sur le terrain d'ailleurs
hier il y avait en bas de chez moi
la la la la manifestation des pompiers
la situation est en train de virer au
chaos
monsieur macron doit retirer cette
réforme et s'il ne le fait pas eh bien
nous lorsque nous serons arrivés au
pouvoir nous reviendrons au système
antérieur
une dernière petite question puisqu'on
arrive à la fin de cette interview qui
d'après vous parmi ces personnalités
ferait un meilleur roi moi mon président
qu emmanuel macron cet intitulé
c'est un sondage ipsos pour le point 23
personnalités
vous n'êtes pas dedans alors que vous
aviez eu les parrainages en a vu
concourir à la dernière élection
présidentielle vous l'expliquez comment
je l'expliqué par le fait que les
instituts de sondage systématiquement
font comme si le père n'existait pas
nous avons de nombreux témoignages
d'adhérents
écoutez c'est que je ne sais pas comment
le qualifier mais c'est un fait que les
instituts de sondages font comme si nous
n'existions pas d'ailleurs à part rt
france épée qui sud radio
nous avons les plus grandes difficultés
a même passé dans les médias est ce que
vous trouvez normal par exemple alors
que tout le monde sait qu ont certains
m'appellent monsieur fréq site que j'ai
créé le parti du fric si que depuis
bientôt treize ans je milite pour le
fric site
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
depuis les élections présidentielles je
n'ai jamais été invité sur tf1
est ce que vous trouvez normal que
depuis les élections européennes je n'ai
jamais été invité sur france 2 qui est
payé par les contribuables
c'est à dire que nous avons 1 2% des
français qui ont voté pour l'upm
normalement nous devrions passer
régulièrement ne serait ce que parce que
nous finançons le service public de
l'audiovisuel
nous ne sommes jamais invités et ce sont
les instituts de sondage qui le font je
donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui nous
suivent sur rupert tv huppert tv sur
youtube nous nouvelle salon de records
en records puisque on va franchir
bientôt et 130 mille abonnés et puis
notre si tu perds point fr qui le site
le plus consulté de tous les partis
politiques français
c'est la revanche du bouche à oreille et
d'internet contre le verrouillage des
médias et des instituts de sondage merci
françois cellino d'avoir été avec nous